hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar titled
repurposing and copin 19.
can we identify new antivirals we are so
glad you could join us for the
coronavirus virtual event series
and we hope you are doing well and
staying safe i'm xavier gutierrez of
labyrinths and i'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots
now before we begin i would like to
remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you would like
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send i answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation and if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen as a
reminder
this presentation is educational and
offers free continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i now present today's speaker dr sarah
cherry
professor of pathology and laboratory
medicine and microbiology at pearlman's
school of medicine
university of pennsylvania for a
complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr cherry you may now begin your
presentation
much i'm really delighted to be here
today to talk to you about
our recent work trying to identify
new antivirals that might be active
against the sars coronavirus
so as you know over the last few months
this pandemic has spread across the
globe
and infected a huge number of people
these are data from about a month ago
really demonstrating that the virus has
really
become a pandemic across the globe
and so in trying to think about how we
can have an impact on this
horrible disease there are sort of two
major
approaches that are being taken by a
variety of investigators across the
globe
so one is the development of vaccines
in order to prevent the initial
infection of individuals
and there are a large number of groups
and companies
pursuing this avenue in addition the
other approach which is the one that
we're taking
is trying to identify drugs that might
be active against stars coronavirus
in order to ameliorate disease uh once
people are infected
and so the sars chronovirus is an rna
virus
and all viruses have to co-opt and
subvert
many pathways and processes within a
host cell in order to replicate
so they're obligate intracellular
parasites and so
they have to bind to host cells they
have to
enter those host cells by crossing a
membrane to get into the cytoplasm
and then once in the cytoplasm viruses
have to make more of themselves
they use the host translation machinery
to make more proteins
and they use their own machinery as well
as cellular machinery
in order to make additional copies of
their rna genomes
in addition to make mrnas to be
translated
so once this virus can replicate the
high levels
it can undergo assembly and exit
in order to infect the next cells so
all viruses use their own encoded
machinery
and so those are potential drug targets
as well as all of the myriad of of
cellular proteins that are required
to allow the virus to replicate within
cells and
uh promote infection so that leads to
sort of the two main classes of
antivirals which we're trying to
identify
so there are the ones that are called
direct acting antivirals so those are
the ones that are targeting
these viral proteins that are essential
for replication
so a really good example of that is run
desevere so around desevere
is a small molecule drug that can target
the virally encoded rna-dependent rna
polymerase
that's required for the virus to
replicate so if you can block the
activity of the rna-dependent rna
polymerase
then you can block replication of the
virus and so rem desevier has shown
efficacy in clinical trials and is being
more widely used
so there are lots of other viral
proteins that are required
to allow the virus to replicate and
targeting those viral proteins would
also potentially allow you
to block viral replication another group
of direct
acting antivirals that there's a lot of
work being done
around are the identification of
neutralizing antibodies
so many individuals who are infected
with the virus develop antibodies and
those antibodies help the person to
clear infection
but then it can they also help to
prevent re-infection
so if you could identify highly active
neutralizing antibodies from for example
an infected individual you could either
directly use that
those antibodies to block infection in a
new individual
and that's what the convalescent serum
trials are based on
or you could create drugs from those
antibodies directly
and those are called therapeutic
antibodies and one example are these
nanobodies that are being developed
so that's not another group of
antivirals that directly bind to the
virus to block infection for example
there are another group of antivirals
that
can be very active and those are called
the host targeted antivirals
so these are drugs that can target human
proteins
so as i said the virus has to bind to
cell surface receptors
it has to get triggered to enter into
the cytoplasm
it has to create more rnas and more
proteins and it uses much of the host
machinery
in order to accomplish these tasks so if
you could target any of the human
proteins that are required for this
process
then you would be able to block the
ability of the virus to establish
infection so there are many examples of
the development
of therapeutics against human proteins
for example
entry factors so as i said the bio the
virus has to bind to cell surface
receptors
and sars2 uses a protein called ace2
as the receptor so if you could somehow
block ace2
or block the interaction between the
virus and ace2 for example
then you could block the ability for the
virus to enter cells
additionally the virus has to be
triggered uh in order to enter cells and
we'll talk more about that later
and so if you could block the triggering
mechanism again you could block the
ability of the virus to establish
infection
and so you could then use those as
therapeutics
another example of host targeted
antivirals are a bit more indirect
or or they can be direct in infected
cells and those are called
immunomodulators so if you could
modulate the immune system of an
individual for example by inducing
early immunity you might be able to
block the ability of the virus to
establish infection
and one of the pathological consequences
of infection with this virus
has to do with an increased cytokine
production
which can cause inflammation and other
coagulation defects and so
again if you could modulate this immune
response
you might be able to ameliorate at least
disease if not viral replication
and so there's a variety of approaches
towards the discovery of
immunomodulators
which would again either block infection
directly or ameliorate the pathogenesis
associated
with this infection so we're interested
in identifying
both classes of antivirals in order to
get
our best chance at being able to impact
disease outcomes
so this brings us to the question of
well how would we find these drugs and
and how would we do this so
my lab is an academic lab and um
we have access to uh available drugs
and so we began to think about whether
or not we could repurpose approved
drugs for use against this this newly
emerged virus
so there are many drugs that have been
approved in humans so there are about 3
500 current fda approved drugs
and this is a the circular uh
pie chart is showing you what these were
what these target so they can target a
diverse array
of different cellular targets and they
were
you know developed for many different
diseases from cancer
to immune problems to neuronal
neuronal problems so one could consider
them
we don't actually know which cellular
proteins are required for replication so
maybe
inadvertently the virus uses some ion
channel
for which we have an inhibitor and if we
treated cells or
individuals with that inhibitor we could
block infection
so the idea here is that there are many
approved drugs and the question is
are any of them active to block sars2
replication
so one would of course start by thinking
about antivirals
approved antivirals and in fact there
are very few
actually approved antivirals the numbers
that one can find as of 2016
there are actually only 70 fda approved
antivirals
but that is that is also another place
to look for
antivirals that might also act against
sars2
in fact remdesavir the drug that i
mentioned earlier
that's been approved against sars2 was
actually first developed against a
different rna virus
and it was found to also have activity
against this virus
so again the idea of repurposing or
reusing drugs that were developed for
some other
reason really has um potentially
great utility so once we
once we thought about which drugs we
might want to look at we had to
come up with a strategy for identifying
antivirals
and so i'm also the scientific director
of the high throughput screening corps
here at penn
where we have robotics and we have drug
libraries that we use
routinely to screen for antivirals
with other viruses as well as other
biologies
so we were able to rapidly obtain the
stars
ii coronavirus and develop a
pipeline to screen for drugs that were
antiviral
so what we do is we take a multi uh well
tight multi-well plates so we use 384
well plates
and we can seed them with cells and then
we can use robotics to add the drugs to
the cells
and then infect them with the sars covi
tube
and we do that in the bsl 300
containment
so that way no one can inadvertently get
infected with the virus
so then we let the virus replicate
within cells and then we
fix and stain the cells and use
automated microscopy to image
uh each well to ask whether or not
the drug that we put in that well
impacts the ability of the virus to
establish infection
so here is an example where we have some
wells where
on the left there's a well with no
activity so you can see lots of blue
dots those are
the total number of cells in the well
and you can see lots of green dots and
those are the infected cells
and if we identify an antiviral what
we're looking for
or well is where the cells are still
viable so that the drug is not set a
toxic
but that it can block the ability for
the virus to establish
infections so they'll be blue but not
green cells
and so this is the strategy that we've
undertaken
and then the question is well again
where are we going to get these drug
libraries
so what we've done is we've put together
our own in-house libraries as well as
collaborated with a number of different
groups
in order to bring in additional
libraries
so we've uh basically purchased all the
antivirals that have been reported in
the literature
we have our own in-house repurposing
library within the high throughput
screening core
pen we've begun work or we've been
working with medicines for malaria
venture
so they um have a their own uh
set of compounds that include uh
chloroquine which was first developed
for malaria and all the chloroquine
derivatives
we've been working with the national
center for advancing translational
science our
ncats and they've provided us for
another
2 500 drugs uh in their repurposing
libraries
and we've also collaborated with caliber
and the gates foundation
where we've obtained another 12 000
drugs um and that's
uh screen is actually almost uh complete
so we're really trying to capture as
much uh space as we can to identify
drugs are active
again uh against stars kovi 2 um
in our screening assays
so the idea here is to go from our high
throughput screens where we can screen
thousands of compounds
to then go into validation mode where we
basically
do dose responses in a variety of cell
types
to determine the activity of the
antiviral and how toxic it is to look at
cytotoxicity
and then to take our most potent and
non-toxic
kits and move them into resp primary
respiratory cells so as
most of you probably know the virus is a
respiratory pathogen
and can infect both the nasal epithelium
as well as uh the airways and bronchial
epithelial cells
so we have a number of models in the lab
where we can directly test drugs on
these
primary mature cells and then the idea
is to take these into pre-clinical
testing
and for example hamster and mouse models
to then ultimately
bring these um compounds to clinical
trials
so this is really our our our pipeline
that we're
trying to accomplish in order to
ultimately get
new therapeutics into the clinic okay
so where are we so we started like i
said a few months ago
when we were able to obtain the virus i
think that was in
late february february early march
and so the first thing we had to do is
develop this microscopy based assay
to look to see if we can identify
antivirals
and so vero cells are an african green
monkey cell line that are used by
many many investigators and it's really
the cell line of choice to grow many
viruses in
including stars cov2 so in fact we
initially amplified the virus in these
cells so we knew that these cells were
highly permissive
and so the first thing we did was try to
develop a robust microscopy based assay
to quantify the number of infected cells
so here i'm showing you again some
microscopy images of either
uninfected cells or asura's kov2
infected cells
that we could stain for two different
viral antigens so one
is anti-double-stranded rna and that's
shown in red
and the other is anti-spike shown in
green and so double-stranded rna
is an intermediate in the rna
replication cycle of this virus
and so uh infected cells have very
bright double-stranded rna staining
and spike is the receptor for the virus
um the glycoprotein and so that also is
obviously made
when the virus is replicating in cells
so using this microscopy based astay we
then had to validate that we could
that we could in fact observe an
antiviral and quantify
the antiviral activity and so we began
using uh two different uh drugs
one uh is an entry inhibitor and it's
hydroxychloroquine
so this was in early days when uh
hydroxychloroquine
was really being touted as a potent
antiviral
and so we also found in these viral
cells that we could
inhibit infection with
hydroxychloroquine
um and concentrations that were not
toxic so in all of my slides the green
lines will be toxicity and the blue
lines will be
the percentage of infection so as the
percentage of infection goes down
that that shows antiviral activity
so we in addition to hydroxychloroquine
we also tested
um rem de severe which is what i s what
i earlier
discussed which is uh an inhibitor of
the rna-dependent rna polymerase from
the virus
and so that blocks rna replication
so hydroxychloroquine blocks entry by
de-acidifying endosomes so the entry
pathway
at least in some contexts is dependent
on an acid ph
compartment so hydroxychloroquine um
dissolves that ph gradient and so the
virus
uh can't be in this low ph compartment
and so can't trigger
and the second room deciber actually
targets a viral protein so that's a host
targeting molecule and a viral targeting
molecule
but given that we were able to
quantitatively measure
both toxicity and infection we then went
on to screen
uh some of our drug libraries so here
i'm showing you
the screen at one micromolar on vero
cells of about three thousand drugs
where the ones on the left that go down
are the drugs that block infection and
the ones that go up
i guess somewhat increase infection but
we're looking for the antivirals here
and so there were six drugs that made
our cutoffs for an antiviral
and so um we took those six drugs
and tested them in dose response and
four of them
had sub micromolar antiviral activity
and low toxicity so they're shown here
where
again you can see the blue lines show
quite potent activity
and the green lines um are uh
distinct from the blue line so that is
at the active concentrations the
drugs are not toxic but it was a little
bit surprising to us
that only let's say four drugs out of
the 3000
were active because um within that
library of 3000 were many many drugs
that have been re reported by
many other investigators as being active
so this made us think a little bit
harder about the differences between our
assay and many other people's assays
and so one might have been the cutoffs
so we we drew our cutoff at 60
inhibition so that's only actually a
little bit more than two-fold
which we felt was um generous and then
the other thing that we
um incorporated into our cut-offs was
cell death because we had a readout for
cell death within every well and so we
also removed any um compounds that were
toxic
that had more than 20 percent death at
the at the concentration
uh reported but again we were a little
bit surprised at how few drugs were
antiviral
we'll talk a little bit on that about
some of these in a minute um
uh as we discuss some of the other
screens that we've done
okay so then we decided well you know
the vera cells are an african degree
monkey cell they've been in culture for
decades they're really permissive to
many many viruses so they're defective
for many pathways that
are presumably important in normal cells
so we decided that what we really
were interested in is screening in human
cells right so
um the first human cell that we found
that was permissive to infection
was a human hepatocyte cell line called
huh 7.5
and the reason we tested these early on
and and one of the reasons
um maybe they're so permissive is that
they're actually
a cell line that's routinely used for
many other viruses including
a hepatitis c virus which um can't
replicate in most cell lines and so
it's thought that the reason that it's
most permissive is because it's
defective for innate immune signaling
and so we reason that maybe these would
be more permissive to sars cov2 as well
as they're more permissive to many other
viruses and so indeed we were able to
show
uh early on that stars cov2
could infect uh these human hepatocyte
cells
and so again i'm showing you here the
micrograph
of a plus and minus infection
using the double-stranded rna
antibody and again we looked at the two
known inhibitors the entry inhibitor
hydroxychloroquine
and the rna replication inhibitor rem
desevere and again we could show very
potent activities for these
uh inhibitors in these cells
okay so then again we screened the
library
and we identified 33 drugs
that were active so this was way more
than in viral cells and in dose
responses
looking at activity versus toxicity
uh 23 of them validated so
um and three of the 23 of the uh
the validated hits were um the
within the vero hits so three of the
four vero hits
were also active in these human
hepatocytes
okay and so this is a now a pie chart of
the 23
drugs that we validated in dose response
and they fall into a number of different
categories
and again we'll talk more about them in
detail in a minute but some of these
categories were what were
what actually we expected um to come out
as antiviral
so i'm showing you some examples of
these different categories here
so for example it's known that that
there are proteases that are required
for
um infection and that's actually why
hydroxychloroquine
can block infection because um the acid
ph
is required to activate cathepsins which
are proteases that are acid dependent
and so indeed we found that the
cathepsin inhibitors
were antiviral in these cells so that's
here
for example there's another example of
kinase inhibitors so it's known that
many viruses are dependent on kinase
signaling pathways
for their activity and we identified a
number of kinase inhibitors one of which
here is shown as an mtor inhibitor
and we identified drugs in a number of
other categories including
um an epigenetic drug and drugs against
epigenetic factors
and other gpcrs for example
so that was really exciting to us that
we were ident able to identify
additional targets that seem to be
potently antiviral and
in these human cells but then this leads
to the question of well if there's such
big differences between
the hepatocytes and the vera cells what
about lung epithelial cells because
actually the major target
in humans are in fact the lung
epithelium
and the nasal epithelium so the question
is can we model these
respiratory epithelial cells and and how
many of these drugs are active in that
context
and so the cell line that we um began to
use is a cell line called cal u3
which is being widely used in the in the
um in the field uh because these cells
are very permissive
to source cov2 and so again
we began by looking at whether or not
the known antivirals were active
in these uh cal u3 cells and so i'm just
showing you
again um the picture of that uh entry
pathway
um to to remind you that um there are a
number of different
drugs again that have been shown to be
active including rendezvous so right so
that's the rna dependent rna
polymerase inhibitor and indeed the
direct
acting antiviral is antiviral in the
virus cells the hepatocytes
and the lung epithelial cells but when
we started looking at the
entry inhibitors we were quite surprised
so this is in the vera cells where again
we i'm
re-showing you the hydroxychloroquine
and i'm also showing you
a cathepsin inhibitor and you can see
that both of these drugs have activity
in vera cells but another another drug
chemist which blocks tempers 2 has no
activity in these cells and that's
actually
been shown that these cells don't
express tempers too
so if you go back to the picture on the
left
what has been shown is that the virus
binds the receptor
ace2 and then can be activated for
fusion
by this serine protease uh tempurs2
and so in cells that don't express
tempers 2
like the vera cells it seems that the
virus goes through
this um endocytosis pathway
to a low ph compartment that then allows
cathepsins to cleave
the spike and and trigger fusion again
this is
again what was in the literature at the
time so again we looked in the
hepatocytes and we saw something very
similar right that the acidification
blocker and the cathepsin inhibitors
could block infection but again the
tempus 2 inhibitor chemist had no
effect in these cells in contrast when
we looked in these cal u3 cells
this is where we were quite surprised in
fact hydroxychloroquine
and the cathepsin inhibitor had
absolutely no activity in these cells
while kamistat the tempus 2 inhibitor
was potently antiviral
so these data suggest that maybe the
virus is going through
two completely different pathways
depending on the cell type
but because there is so much literature
about the about chloroquine and
hydroxychloroquine
we looked at a larger panel of these
acidification blockers just to be
certain that there was not something
unique about hydroxychloroquine in these
cells
and so we got a panel of um chloroquine
derivatives working with
medicine for malaria venture and we
tested them
and so this is the data in the parasites
the viral cells and the caliu3 cells
and i hope you can appreciate that in
that if you look at the ic50s
in the hepatocytes these are basically
very very potent antivirals but if you
look at the ic50s in cali3 cells they
basically have no activity at all
so that really shows that it's not
something specific to hydroxychloroquine
but there's something uniquely different
about the entry pathways that are used
in different cell types
so it seems that in cells that don't
express tempers to
the virus is exclusively dependent upon
the endosomal entry pathway and the
activity of cathepsins
while in cells that express tempers too
the virus is exclusively dependent on
tempers too so that these pathways are
actually not redundant in cells but
actually the virus moves
through completely different pathways in
different cell types and so this has
really important implications
for treating humans because as we all
know the hydroxychloroquine trials
were um did not show efficacy in humans
and
i would uh hypothesize that this may be
because
in the in the respiratory epithelium
where the virus
is replicating to high levels um the
virus is not dependent on acidification
for entry
whereas it's actually very dependent on
the tempus 2
and sensitive to camistad
so now that we have this cal u3 model
where we can look to
and determine whether or not antivirals
or potential antivirals are active
in the respiratory epithelium we took
the 23 antivirals that we found were
active
against um thesaurus coronavirus 2
in the hepatocytes and asked whether or
not they were active in the lung
epithelial cells
and actually consistent with what i just
told you about how some of the pathways
are completely different in different
cell types
only nine of the 23 antivirals were
active in cal u3s
so these are the ic50 curves for the
nine antivirals
that showed some activity in the caliu3
cells and you can see
by looking at just the shapes of these
curves that some of them are more active
than others
some of them show some toxicity but
there are a handful of them that seem to
be very active
in these cal u3 cells suggesting that we
should think harder
about what their mechanisms of action
might be and whether or not they're
um active in in
primary models so one one thing that we
feel is really important is is to
perform a different kind of assay so
what i've been showing you throughout
is this microscopy based assay where
we're quantifying you know per cell
using a microscope whether or not a cell
is infected or uninfected
but another straightforward assay to
look at the level of viral replication
is to do rtq pcr for viral rna
to ask how much is the viral rna
affected
by these antivirals and so we developed
a sensitive rtq pcr assay
to look at whether or not antivirals
were active
so this is a graph of the change in
viral rna when we treat it treat with
these
um nine drugs as well as rem desevere
so if you look at the first bar we've
set the untreated infected
well or cells to one and that when we
would
treat the cells with rendezvous we have
more than a three log
reduction in viral rna so consistent
with the curves i'm showing you
ramzabira is very active in blocking
viral replication in cell culture
and so then you can see the the um the
remaining drugs that we identified
uh that validated in the ic50 curves
that that all of them had a reduction of
at least one log and some of them
had a multi-log reduction in viral rna
suggesting
that they might be very potent
antivirals
so just to remind you
of the pie chart that i showed you of
these different classes of antivirals
and again only nine of them were active
some of the classes
um didn't show up at all in the lung
epithelial cells so one group is the
protease inhibitors
that they're a number of them were
active in the hepatocytes and none of
them were active
in the cal u3 cells suggesting that
these proteases might all be targeting
directly or indirectly
some aspect of this endosomal entry
pathway
we were also um disappointed to be
honest
that the the two epigenetic inhibitors
that we had identified and validated in
the patasites
also didn't validate in the uh
lung epithelial cells and also a number
of kinase inhibitors
um did not did not validate so
there were just sort of a number of of
drugs some were expected some
unanticipated that that did not show
activity
in the lung epithelial model um
but we did like i said validate uh nine
drugs so i want to
tell you a little bit about uh these
nine antivirals
so four of them are approved drugs and
those are cyclosporine
celinomycin an h1 antihistamine
and an egf receptor inhibitor so these
uh all showed efficacy in um
in the cal u model as well as in
hepatocytes because that's where we
identified them
uh and uh i think it's quite interesting
that we identified this
h1 antihistamine in a bastine as uh
antiviral because this is approved all
over
asia and there are clinical trials um
happening right now
so we're really um hoping to see some
activity with these
um and with this class of antivirals
we also identified two uh
receptor tyrosine kinase inhibitors like
i said an egfr
inhibitor which is actually an approved
drug uh as well as an inhibitor against
a um
a gene called axel so egfr is a classic
growth factor receptor
and actually has been shown to promote
entry for many viruses
and we're currently determining whether
or not it's
promoting entry of this virus and axel
is a well-known attachment
factor so many many viruses uh bind to
axel
in order to um increase their ability to
be
um internalized into uh cells
and actually there's a fast-track trial
um in in britain
uh testing bemcentinib in uh in clinical
trials in humans so again we're really
interested in seeing how those uh trials
play out given that
these two drugs seem to be quite potent
um in blocking
viral infection in these respiratory
epithelial cells
so one question is
is if if these genes are important
is their downstream signaling important
for viral infection
and in fact we have identified two
different
mtor inhibitors which is a kinase that's
known to be downstream of receptor
tyrosine kinases
and we identified these two different uh
mtor inhibitors and interestingly both
of these drugs
target both mtor1 and mtor2
and that seems to be important for their
activity because in the library we had a
large number of what are called rapalogs
or rapamycin derivatives
which um don't target uh both mtor1 and
m2
so it suggests that uh targeting both of
those kinases
is what's required and again we're
testing if that activity
is downstream of these receptor tyrosine
kinases
okay so then we identified a few other
drugs so one thing we identified is um
sorry our iron chelator uh which
seems to be antiviral and because of the
some of the pathology in humans could be
related to increased iron in patients
and the fact that iron chelaters can be
impact endothelial inflammation
there's actually a clinical trial
underway with related iron chelators so
again
it will be interesting to to see how
these play out
and then we identified two drugs with
unknown targets
selenamycin and y320
celinomycin is actually an approved drug
that's being used in cancer and we've
actually identified a number of
analogues of selenium ice in their
um antiviral so we're really interested
in trying to uncover
uh what the target might be of
solenomycin that's causing it to be
so potently antiviral
so um that's this group
so the uh the last um drug that i from
this um
screen that i really want to talk about
is our identification
of cyclosporine so um
cyclosporin is a an approved
immunosuppressant
um and it's it works through the
inhibition of the interaction between
cyclothon
and calcineurin and so blocking
calcineurin blocks immune activation
and so that's how that's why it's used
as an immunosuppressant but actually
cyclophyllin and calcineurin activity
have shown to be
um to impact many different viral
infections and in fact
um including many of the uh related
coronaviruses to saurus club u2
and so we're interested in understanding
how um
how cyclosporine was antiviral and
whether or not that might be a
clinically tractable
approach so like i said cyclosporine
blocks the
uh the activity of uh calcineurin by
impacting the interaction between
cyclothon and calcineurin
so it actually blocks both of these
proteins activity
so we were under wanted to discover if
the activity was through calcineurin or
through
inhibition of cyclophyllin and so we
treated cells with fk 506
which just blocks calcineurin and not
cyclophyllin and that did not show
activity
and we also tested an n-fat inhibitor so
n-fat is one of the major targets
downstream of calcineurin
and so we used an inhibitor against
n-fat to ask if that
was antiviral and it was not so together
these data suggested that cyclophyllin
was what was
was uh important for viral infection and
that if we could just target
cyclophyllin
that that might uh control infection
and so we tested a drug called nem-811
which is in fact a cyclosporine analog
that targets cyclophyllin but not
calcineurin and we found that that was
active so again all together this data
suggests that the
inhibition of cyclophyllin is what's
antiviral
and that the inhibition of calcineurin
is not important
for the antiviral activity of
cyclosporine
so again we we wanted to verify these
results using
an independent assay and we did the qpcr
assay
in both the h7 cells the
hepatocytes and the respiratory cells
and we could see that in both cases
both cyclosporine and this nem811
could block infection suggesting that
they were uh bona fide antivirals
and interestingly we don't see any of
these activities in these viral cells
again suggesting that there are
fundamental differences between vero
cells
and not viral cells okay
so there's actually a drug called
allosporovir
which is an oral drug that was
used in clinical trials for its activity
against hepatitis c
virus and so it was really
it was used in this clinical trial where
they did a randomized trial
combining alice borovir with the
standard of care in in hepatitis c virus
peg interferon and riboviron
and um and it didn't show any benefit
over the the current therapy but it also
suggests that alice borovir may be
um an orally available antiviral that
might be able to be used against our
scoby too so we tested
alice borovir in caliu3 cells and
was able to show that alice borovir had
in fact
activity against source code v2 and
caliu3 cells
so that became somewhat exciting to us
we also just
um because of the difficulties in
working with soros kovi 2
to to think about whether or not um this
allosporovir
might be active against other
coronaviruses so this is a diagram
of different coronaviruses and then the
red boxes are the ones
that are pathogenic to humans and have
caused um
outbreaks in the last decade or so and
so
other of these are actuating actually
viruses that
infect us all the time and cause sort of
a common cold
and one of these viruses that these
common circulating viruses that we
obtained
is a virus called oc-43 and so we wanted
to see
if uh these analogues were antiviral
against oc-43
and indeed um oc43 infects these hrh 7.5
cells and in our preliminary data we've
been able to show that both nematode 11
and alice borovir can block oc43
replication
again suggesting not only that alice
borovir might be
a good candidate but that it may be a
really
antiviral against coronaviruses in
general
which would be um really useful uh in
the future
in case of any um new new
outbreaks and of other coronaviruses in
in coming years so then the question of
course is whether or not
it's antiviral in primary cells so you
know we're getting
you know more and more relevant by
moving from veros
to human cells to these respiratory
cells but these are also not primary
cells
and so we've begun to to test some of
our candidates
in primary cell models so
um one model that we have are these are
primary human bronchial epithelial cells
and we've been able to show by our rtq
pcr essay
that both cyclosporine and alisporovir
show
activity against the virus
in addition we have human ips cell
derived type 2 alveolar epithelial cells
and again we were able to show that both
cyclosporine and alice borovir
have activity against the virus
suggesting again
that we may be able to um repurpose
alice borovir for use
uh in this uh against this virus
so future studies are aimed at trying to
validate the results in animal models to
really
determine how active it may be and how
much disease it might be able to
ameliorate but i think
you can take away from from uh this
this talk that we really think that we
have to look
directly in respiratory cells if we're
really going to find antivirals that are
active
so using the assay that we developed in
cal u3 cells we've screened
our library our repurposing library and
identified
88 candidates that were antiviral in
these cells
16 of which are fda approved drugs so i
just want to give you a flavor
of what we identified so we found a
different additional nucleosides that
are antiviral
so some are shown here where we found
that um for example mercaptopurine and
other
nucleosides that are used in cancer
therapies are
active against um saris clv2
we also identified additional tempus 2
inhibitors so in addition to camistat
we found a another um
tempers2 inhibitor in the thermostat is
highly active
against the virus in these cells
we identified additional signaling
inhibitors so kinase inhibitors that
were antiviral
and so i just want to point out so i had
already told you that in the hepatocyte
screen
we identified egf our inhibitors
but actually in this screen we also
identified in addition dgfr
and tor inhibitors we also identified
map kinase inhibitors so the two main
pathways downstream of egfr
seem to be really important for
promoting a viral infection and we're
again trying to
characterize the mechanisms by which
this works
so hopefully i've i've convinced you
that there's a number of important
lessons that we've learned and really
we're moving
uh these studies in in new directions so
one thing is that i think there are
major differences in cell types
so they're just how the virus moves
through different cells is really
um an important facet and so you have to
use relevant study
cells to discover antivirals that are
active
so viral cells may be good to find
direct acting antivirals but not
necessarily for host directed antivirals
and
this is also captured in rna-seq data
where we took either calu3s or
these hepatocytes and infected them with
the virus and looked at what genes
are induced upon infection and you can
see there's very little overlap and even
in the responses of these cells to
infection
so again we really need to remember that
the virus is
infecting normally very specialized
cells
i do think the entry pathways are good
targets but we need to model this
correctly we can't just assume
everything will be the same in different
cell types
i personally think cyclophilline is a
clinically actionable target and we're
trying to get this into preclinical
models
to determine in fact how well on the
cyclophyllin inhibitors work in vivo
we've identified additional targets some
of which i've mentioned and we're
continuing to validate all the
candidates that
we think are potentially useful
in primary these primary cell models and
additional models that we're
working on these days as i said we're
screening additional libraries and cal
u3 cells and we're actually
have screened these libraries against
the common cold virus oc 43 to try to
understand the similarities and
differences
between host factor dependencies in the
of these different viruses
and then the last point i want to make
is we're currently doing
synergy studies to try to identify
combinations of drugs
that are most potent so you know for hiv
and hepatitis c virus we treat people
with cocktails of antivirals in order to
block infection
and that may be what we need to do here
with sars kovi 2
and so we're trying to take our our best
candidates and look
uh in two by two dose responses to ask
if there's any interactions or
or any increase in potency if we combine
them so for example here you can see
the percent inhibition of infection if
we
either dose and run desevere or canister
and then we can take this data and ask
if the if the expected values are
different
than just um you know independent uh
antiviral activity and so we use a model
called
uh bliss to to quantify that and what we
found for example with this combination
is that there's no
uh interaction between rem desevere and
the entry inhibitor chemist at and so
we're doing large scale combinations now
to see if we can identify combinations
that are
additive or synergistic in order to
really come up with the best strategy
moving forward so with that i'd just
like to thank the members of my lab
uh and the members of the high
throughput screening corps in particular
david schultz
as well as all of our collaborators who
have contributed to various aspects of
this
um as well as our external
collaborations that have provided
either funding or drugs or suggestions
on how to move forward with some of
these
candidates with that i'll take any
questions thank you
well thank you dr sherry for your
informative presentation
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar and if you have any questions
you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on that
click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
now let's get started our first question
is going to be are in vitro hansing
and are in vitro enhancing antibodies
disqualify for coveted treatment
um well we're not really working on
therapeutic antibodies but
um i i don't haven't seen much data on
on antibodies that enhance infection so
this virus infection
is quite different than some of the
others that
where antibodies can enhance infectivity
that's not really been shown
to my knowledge in stars cov2 infection
and how long after infection can
antibodies against sars kobe 2 still be
detected in someone's blood
well i mean the the outbreak only
started a few months ago and so uh
obviously still we can detect antibodies
and most people who have been infected
i think that to answer that question we
have to wait a lot longer
after infection to see whether or not
they decline
differently than other kinds of viral
infections but it's a really important
question
which has really big impacts on the
vaccine strategies that are being used
so the assumption is that that
antibodies either
from infection or that are elicited to a
vaccine
would last a reasonable amount of time
to protect from reinfection
and do the antibody levels correlate
with the disease severity and long-term
immunity so the studies that i know
about
that actually patients that are
hospitalized have some of the highest
antibody levels so there's some question
about whether or not the flavor of the
antibodies are different but
the absolute amount of antibodies um
are quite high in hospitalized patients
suggesting that there's not
a direct correlation between these
values
looks like we have one more question as
you're speaking through all the
antivirals that are being tested
which look the which look the most
promising and how many clinical trials
does it take
to safely say quote unquote it works
um yeah so
i think that a handful of the
antivirals that we've identified um
are tractable with the time frame
consistent with this outbreak so in
order to move something
into the clinic soon it will have
already had to have gone through phase
one or phase two
trials so that means taking only drugs
that are already approved for something
else
and repurposing them so we've only
identified a handful of those
and of those we're trying to get
pre-clinical testing and rodent models
in order to show efficacy against stars
kov2
in an animal and only those that would
go
that showed efficacy would potentially
move forward
in terms of saying it works that's a
more complicated question
but you would need you need randomized
clinical trials that have defined
endpoints and if we if you had um
you know strong signal in a randomized
clinical trial with
to find endpoints then you would at
least have
some signal but saying something works
is
is complicated right because unless it's
a a home run
it's going to take it takes a lot of of
testing in various humans so rendezvous
is a good example of that that it
certainly shows activity
but it's it's not black and white
that was the last of our questions dr
cherry do you have any final comments
for the audience
um no i don't think so i mean i think
that
it's really important for us to to push
forward both vaccines and therapeutics
both for this outbreak and future
outbreaks and i'm really hopeful that
uh between all the different approaches
being taken that we'll
find something active and be able to
impact the outbreak
sometime soon
well thank you again dr cherry for your
time today and your important research
we really appreciate you um before we go
i'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on demand
for six months to march of 2021
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's event
until next time goodbye